welcome back to the David Pakman show I
am fair and cousins sitting in for David
Pakman today in case you hadn't been
following along with the Jared Kushner
saga that's been going on in New York
City a few months ago was announced that
Jared Kushner and Kushner companies had
filed false paperwork with the city of
New York and and the regulators in New
York the housing regulators basically
saying that a building he had bought
that he purchased that he wanted to flip
and make a huge profit off of the
paperwork they filed showed that they
had no rent controlled tenants in that
building whatsoever and as a result of
that false paperwork that they submitted
which Jared Kushner was directly
involved in falsifying this information
according to reports they were allowed
to go in start all this construction
they could kick people out of their
apartments which they did and it turns
out that was all illegal and was all
based on falsified information that news
came out a few months ago an
investigation was launched in this week
finally we have a resolution to the
story and that is that New York City
Housing regulators have fined Jared
Kushner and his business two hundred and
ten thousand dollars that is a
pathetically weak and disgusting
punishment for what the Kushner
companies did two hundred and ten
thousand dollars submitting fraudulent
information to the New York Housing
Authority off which they made millions
of dollars and they get fined two
hundred and ten thousand dollars they
made millions off the deal after
renovating this apartment building and
selling it and selling off the condos in
it they made millions and now they get
to keep most of that profit that was
ill-gotten because they kicked people
out of their apartment that legally
couldn't be kicked out of their
apartment where's the remedy for these
people how where's the remedy for the
people who had been living comfortably
in this building in rent-controlled
apartments low-income people for the
most part what do they get are you gonna
give them part of that two hundred and
ten thousand dollars because I guarantee
you're not the remedy at this point for
those people who had to suffer the
injustice --is that Jared Kushner put
them through is a civil lawsuit because
now we know okay according to these
regulators in New York City is without a
doubt 100% that Kushner companies filed
this false paperwork they did something
illegal illegally kicking these people
out of their apartments so a civil
lawsuit could and should immediately be
filed by these people who fraudulently
lost their apartments at the hands of
Jared Kushner and they need to find out
exactly how much profit this man made
off of that building and sue him for
every single penny of it because I can
promise you now that we have regulators
who have determined that yes they acted
fraudulently and filed false information
this is a slam dunk lawsuit this is a
lawsuit that even a very poorly skilled
attorney would be able to win against
the Kushner companies hey Rudy Giuliani
could probably handle this case and win
it without a doubt that's how easy it
would be at this point but that is what
these tenants need to do not just to
stick it to Jared Kushner but to send a
message Kushner companies are not the
only people out there in the United
States who are doing things like this
this happens in every major city from
coast to coast and border to border here
in the United States they need to be
held accountable and when you have
regulators who come in and say okay
we've determined they did something
wrong this is horrible give us a couple
hundred thousand and we'll call it a day
right forty two false documents Kushner
companies filed with the city of New
York 42 so we're talking about 42 counts
of falsified information at this point
and yes I I do see a pattern developing
with Jared Kushner
and the fact that this man cannot seem
to submit a correct document to anyone
to save his life that's why it took him
so long to finally get a security
clearance because he just couldn't help
but you know fudge things on that
application or oops accidentally leave
things off but this man made millions of
dollars by making other people suffer
and this is a story that happens
frequently here in the United States our
regulatory systems state level federal
level local level they are failing us
they are failing citizens but more
importantly they're failing low-income
citizens because if you've got money if
you are in the top 1% top 5% probably
even the top 10% those regulators are
going to make sure they've got your back
and if you break one of their rules
they're gonna let you off as easy as
possible
doesn't matter how many poor people
you've screwed over doesn't matter how
many people you've kicked out of the
only home they've ever known if you've
got the money you can get away with it
because the regulators are in your
pocket the regulator's aren't there to
work for the average people the citizens
the tenants they're there to work for
the top 1% for the rich people they
always have been
or at least throughout my lifetime
always have been it was a time in this
country and it wasn't that way this
wasn't always the story this wasn't the
way things worked but it is now and
that's what we have to focus on the last
remedy that too many people in this
country have is to file a civil lawsuit
to seek some kind of damages against the
people who damaged them because time and
time again regulators at every level
again city state federal they have
proven that they are not going to do
what needs to be done to put people's
lives back together after they have been
taken advantage of by large companies
small companies multinational
corporations it doesn't matter if you
are not in the top 1% you're just a blip
on the
radar for these people but if you've got
money if you're a Kushner if you're a
Trump hell if you're a Clinton yeah you
can kind of get away with things and
it's that way for many people who are
super wealthy in this country people
lost their homes in this Jared Kushner
scam Jared Kushner made millions of
dollars he was fined he in his company
two hundred and ten thousand dollars I
challenge anyone watching this right now
anyone who hears this to explain to me
how that scenario is fair under any
rules anywhere in this country because I
can promise you there is no way to slice
that story that shows that this
punishment to Kushner companies is fair
considering they're still walking away
with millions of dollars in profit